I'm telling you right now if you even if
I hear a [ __ ] breath yeah
all right all right all right thank you
five four three two it is to me it
really is to me my head oh my god I
wrote just now go walking on this true
with my friends listen guys welcome to
their episode of tiger belly it's been a
really interesting week for me great
stuff
interesting stuff she experienced stuff
we you know we did a podcast last week
it was a patreon drop rice almost killed
everyone in the room I went to a red
zone I'm not apologizing for it because
you guys deserved that
mm-hmm so that was a new for you in your
face and I'm gonna tell you right now
[ __ ] that you almost got me in a red
zone again and I'm about to shut this
[ __ ] thing down because I hear
cackling that I don't I don't even know
who that is
now you know what now now I'm gonna sing
the song again
you got coal island well over the Tiger
Valley by the way welcome to Tiger belly
we've got kalila in the room we got
George I mean I swear to [ __ ] god
for a split second I forgot your name
Gilbert you say gave you a burka lon
thank you so much thank you
well let's start over we got a kalila
Gilbert welcome to Tiger Valley Hugh
George beautiful bryce and we have a
[ __ ] guest tonight he literally is
one of my favorites the ugly king of the
east yeah he's a red nut my comrade nut
he's got like some freckles I call him
visual aids he he's so racist he talks
about Chinese people all the time right
yeah when he has for a white dude
Chinese eyes he's been on many many TV
shows he was on a very successful TV
show called mixology it was a hit he got
canceled before it's time
really mixology Lagoo bulette good it's
a good show it's one of the ones and
he's also is one of the ones that you
had to not watch or watch yeah either
way he's also the star of many different
things like the what was that one with
well the room but the other won't the
room they meet made the remake with the
Franco disaster artists he was a big
star on that you know he had a monologue
in there that would suck unbelievable
anyway um but he's also the store of I'm
dying up here which is and Showtime show
about the Comedy Store a very good show
very good show he has his own podcast
called
huh and yeah yeah his name is Andy
Santino give him running welcome now you
can talk what's the matter
yeah go ahead breathe read through it
it's a pleasure to be here thank you
thank you so much for having me on
didn't know you're gonna really
appreciate you know you're gonna be on
today you also don't have a single
freckle yeah I don't have any Bobby just
makes up stuff to make him sound funny
and sweet Bobby
you gave me a bad intro for the first
time in our friendship what do you mean
mixology talk about my cancelled TV show
could I just say the room the disaster
is a movie I literally got cut out of
entirely yep
I'm dying up here yeah my show that
literally just got canceled
yeah okay can I say this oh no yeah no
I'll tell you why go ahead cuz it's your
show this is your room it's your girl
that's your crew I get it your mics your
camera on a vacuum I get it
oh you misunderstood me friend oh no I
got it yeah
oh I got that song what that song I say
yeah before her right right with the
button that you by me and you're walking
down the street yes okay all right I
take it all back you know the street
yeah I was in my head I saw you skipping
down the street with like a bag of
swedish fish that's what I just like
popping them in your mouth
it's the bag of fish that you were
excited about the song was about you and
could I say this too happy to be here
because I read your mythology yeah you
did yeah and I think you're part no yeah
and I didn't even get a callback or
nothing they just went and I left so I
think because it I know that I'm dying
up here yeah I asked I asked my agent I
know it's about the seven he's out up at
the store cuz I cuz that showcase that
they saw Erik Griffin I was on that
showcase the only reason you would have
been on wouldn't have been on the show
yeah because you were you'd be perfect
for it is because there was no Asian
comics in the 70s I know I say this
though I'm serious that's the only
reason our staff was Thai oh yeah
so I even asked that no because that's
not making up that's not a role you
wouldn't do that [ __ ] you didn't get to
you wouldn't get to talk yeah I would
have alliant know you'd want to be
having realign the whiskey fall you know
means Richard Pryor double whiskey
Richard Pryor yeah
and the award for best guest star goes
to Bobby Lee
[Music]